شاكوش يحضر وصلاح يغيب والجدل يجتاح مصر
فما القصه
الفيفا تقول انه واحد من المطربين الذين
اشتهر باغانيه التي تعكس جوانب من الحياه
في العالم العربي وطموحات ابنائه لكن
البعض في الشارع المصري مصاب بالصدمه فاي
صوره عن بلادهم بتاريخها وارثها الضخم
يظهرها حدث بحجم المونديال مع مشاركه مغذي
المهرجانات حسن شاكوش في فعالياته
وما ان تم الاعلان عن مشاركه شاكوش
وفعاليات مونديال قطر حتى انفجر الجدل
المنزعجون اعتبروا الموضوع اهانه لمصر
التي كانت تتمثل في الماضي برمودا مثل ام
كلثوم وعبد الحليم وفي الزمن الحديث
بشخصيه رياضيه مثل محمد صلاح اليوم يمثلها
فنان من لون اخر تماما
الفيفا بررت قرارها بانه جاء بعد ان نجح
حسن شاكوش في تصدر قائمه الاعلى استماعا
على احدى المنصات العالميه للاغاني شاكوش
شارك جمهوره بفرحته العاريمه باختياره
للمشاركه قائلا الحمد والشكر لك يا رب
حلمي بيتحقق الحمد لله
ادي له بالذكرى ان الحفل الذي من المقرر
ان يقدمه سيكون على هامش البطوله للمشجعين
وليس في الافتتاح او الختام